gabler congratulations I'm sure you've
been hearing it all day all night you
are the winner of Survivor season 43 how
are you feeling right now it's
incredible Alyssa a dream come true can
hardly believe it it was a it was just a
remarkable season and adventure of a
lifetime and and I love your show too I
watch your podcast
amazing so let's take it back I want to
talk about the fire making challenge it
had my emotions everywhere I was
exhilarated I was emotional it was all
over the place how confident were you
going into that challenge against Jesse
you know Alyssa I'm an Outdoorsman I
spend a lot of time in the up in the
mountains in Idaho and in the Northwest
in Alaska and I'm pretty good with fire
I knew I'd be okay with it now that said
all through the season I never made fire
because you know other people were doing
it and I kind of kept that up up my
sleeve to when I needed it but um I was
I was pretty confident going into the
Survivor season not just fire making but
I could beat anybody on the beach
absolutely now it was super emotional
between you guys at the end of that like
what was going through your head when
you when that you know that rope broke
and Jesse was very emotional you know
I'm glad you asked that question that's
really nobody's really brought that one
up before but it was really powerful
um when when you vote somebody out on
the game that we love we're all huge
Survivor fans we're all playing our our
hearts out for different reasons
when you vote somebody out you know it's
like okay it's time to vote and the vote
is five to five to two so so and so is
going home
it's a little bit less it's less
personal it's more like okay the tribe
is spoken you're gone when you're making
fire against somebody that you love and
respect who's right next to you and you
know about their family you know about
their Journey you know about his you
know his whole life that he's you know
of of of of you know triumph over
adversity
you know I was obviously excited to win
but it's the exact same moment of
elation I looked over at my friend I'm
getting emotional thinking about right
now it was um it was really it was it
was bittersweet it was hard it was hard
seeing him because it was very personal
like I took Jesse out and you know it
was it was it was weird going back to
Camp it was it was a lot to process that
night
yeah I can only imagine and especially
as a viewer just watching it it was
super powerful and emotional and just
everything so I can only imagine what's
actually like when you're in it and
you've been in there for so long yes
everyone like even more emotional I can
only imagine
um but I also want to talk about like
your triumphs and so many records and
amazing things like speaking of the fire
thoughts was fire making up the whole
it was incredible I couldn't believe it
it was really what Jeff said that yeah I
was very proud because you know making
fire in front of Jeff is Alyssa is
different than making fire anywhere else
I can only imagine as a huge deaf probes
fan I can only imagine him talking to
you while you're also making that fire
yes yes everything and you also you're
the second oldest winner in Survivor
history so many accomplishments so many
things like how if you could sum it up
that feeling how would you sum it up you
know it's it's amazing right you know as
a fan of the show which you are yeah to
go in there and not have your name
written down one time in the entire
season you know until the end you know
which is what you want that was amazing
making the making the merge
um you know winning an individual
immunity winning other immunities
finding an idol I mean it was a pretty
it was a pretty good season I I got to
tell you I felt you know I was as a fan
I wanted to do everything and I'm a
bucket listed a lot of things that
season and I played my heart out out
there like everybody else did and you
know the harder you work the luckier you
get sometimes
there you go I absolutely love that but
I do want to ask you when you went into
final tribal against Cassidy against
Owen
did you have a feeling or a knowledge of
where you thought those votes were going
to lie like were you surprised by how it
all turned out the only vote I was
surprised by was James
um because I thought I would get James's
vote as well
um he was very close with Cassidy but me
and him had a really special bond too if
you go back to the Le vote
um with the merge so emergency
I was immune because my team had one
immunity and I still had my my idol that
was good for my first two tribal
councils right so I'd already been to
one so there's one more and James felt
himself being on the hot seat because he
was being targeted he knew and he's a
smart man he knew it so he came to me
goes gabler
can I have your Idol
and I looked him right in the eye shook
his hand and I said yes sir you can and
that that wasn't shown right but it was
so me and James had that Bond and then
right before Tribal Council I ran back
to him and I go hey I can't give it to
you I have to be able to show it to
Janine right beforehand so she doesn't
play her Idol for Ellie trust me it's
gonna be okay and if you notice on that
Tribal Council whenever the first name
was James you know he he said something
under his breath and he looked down at
me with like a dagger and I'm like it's
cool it's gonna be cool and uh you know
uh sure enough you know Janine did not
player Idol
um and Ellie went home as we had planned
at that point wow that's unreal I love
hearing all this stuff it's so
fascinating to me now I also want to
talk about your another history making
thing that you did for Survivor a
Survivor first you said you were going
to donate your entire prize winnings to
veterans in need I need to know was this
something that you know you had planned
in the beginning or was this something
you were like once you saw okay like I I
definitely have a chance of winning and
then the like switch slip you like this
is what I'm gonna do
so before the show started I was with a
friend of mine who was a roommate from
college who's also in the military we
were sitting around talking with my wife
we said you know what you know gabler if
you make it to the end you know what
about you do something special with the
money and we were kind of joking
tongue-in-cheek but we said it out loud
it made sense you know the the the
blessing of being on the show that I
love the most Survivor and to be able to
play it and play it pretty well
um and to go on that journey into into
myself was powerful and you know to be
just like the grip challenge Alyssa like
the first five minutes of the grip
challenge were the most painful the rest
of it the next 35 minutes were not and
why because I started channeling Heroes
and thinking about things that were more
important than me and I think whenever
we put ourselves in a position to do
something for others we'd find strength
and service is strength and for me to be
able to to honor those who who protected
us and you know the one percent protect
the 99 percent and you know I I had the
opportunity to serve but I never had the
honor but to have the honor to serve
those who served us
still makes me emotional thinking about
it right now
absolutely well I definitely applaud you
for doing that it was very powerful and
very unexpected moment in the show
everyone even Jeff was like wait what's
happening
um but that's true thank you for sharing
your story as well and sharing and
opening and having that discussion
because I think it's very important
um now I do want to just summarize this
and sum it up in the best way possible
obviously you won the grand prize you
got to the end you're donating your
winnings but you also took home some
lifelong memories oh yes ma'am yes ma'am
how would you describe your journey on
Survivor even in like three words or
just in general how would you describe
it yeah I'm going to quote Nietzsche
Will To Power Will To Power
um those are three words that I I live
by you know life is short life is now
and you gotta live it and you know my
journey on Survivor was was about
persistence was about heart was about
being myself and getting to know myself
and
I did it and that's that that was that
was what kept me grounded and kept me
moving forward on those cold nights and
those hot days and those hungry times
you betcha
well it was amazing to see everything
play out it was such an amazing season
full of twists and turns as a Survivor
it's a wild ride
exactly a wild ride and as a Survivor
fan it was amazing to watch and it gets
me even more excited for season 44 like
I can't even believe we're talking about
that now but we just finished season 43
and it was amazing and congratulations
again so well deserved and yeah amazing
congratulations well thank you so much
thank you so much Alyssa Canada I love
you guys you guys are awesome so thank
you Canada thank you Canada